that is zero knowledge thanks very much
so I'm going to talk about some user
knowledge protocols this is join work
from me and Kali that IBM research in
Zurich okay so on my first slide I've
attempted to sort out a few of the
different zero-knowledge protocols from
the literature so vertically I've sorted
them by different cryptographic
assumptions you can see a few there
horizontally they're sorted roughly by
proof size how sick sing the proofs are
for each system and the arrows at least
in my mind show how the different proof
systems have influenced each other okay
so the ones at the bottom based on
lattices and collision resistant hash
functions post quantum secure or
plausibly post quantum secure and the
ones at the top aren't so I used to work
in the orange area of this slide on
discrete logarithm based protocols and
at some point recently I became
interested in the green area so lattice
based zero knowledge protocols and I
think what's really interesting here is
the vertical lines on this diagram so if
you look at chenault's original protocol
a really simple proof of knowledge it's
actually got a lot of similarities with
say some the nest post quantum signature
candidates and you can see some other
similarities in some of these other
vertical lines over here but we also
have a big hole in green area of the
diagram there's nothing in this
logarithmic proof sized section in
particular there's nothing corresponding
to say bullet proof which i think is a
shame because bullet Bruce is a nice
proof system that achieves some good
proof sizes in practice so the real
title of this talk should maybe be how
to try and make bullet proof from
lattices so in this talk I'll talk about
how to use different techniques to prove
knowledge of commitment openings I'll
talk about some basic zero knowledge
proof and how to use bullet proof
techniques and a proof sighs I won't
talk about any of the stuff on the right
hand side but you're welcome to ask me
about that later
it's the first let's talk about proofs
of knowledge and commitments so our task
here is like this we have a
cryptographic commitment that the proven
verify of both know the prover wants to
convince the verifier that they know an
opening to this commitment without
leaking any information so the two are
going to exchange messages and then at
the end the verifier is going to accept
or reject so how do we form eyes this
property that the proven knows an
opening to the commitment well we said
that if there's an adversary against the
protocol who convinces the verify to
accept most of the time then there's
also some kind of knowledge extractor
who uses information from the adversary
to extract an opening to the
cryptographic commitment and that's how
we formalized that this protocol is a
proof of knowledge and approver really
knows how to open the commitment I think
so another another nice clear path
option is you know some kind of like a
juicer for squeezing oranges or
something right
see so you can see that he has you know
he has some kind of special access to
the adversary okay
so in the discrete log setting we often
use Paterson commitments so Paterson
commitments are really easy the
commitment key is just lots of random
group elements from a group sheet where
the discrete log problem is hard and
commit to to commit to some messages si
with some randomness off you just
perform a multi exponentiation with all
the message elements and the group
elements these are really nice
commitments the homomorphic and the
highly compressing taking lots of
messages to a single group element and
we'll see some more properties of
Paterson commitments later well what if
we want to build a lattice based
commitment scheme so that we could use
something like the persist problem the
short integer solution problem so the
input to the problem here is a
collection of random vectors AI from
some finite ring and these will be
vectors of length N and you can solve
this problem by finding a non trivial
linear combination with coefficients si
which is equal to 0 mod Q and this isn't
just any linear combination not just any
si all of the SIS norms have to be
bounded above by by some integer V which
you can think of as being much less than
Q ok so this is supposed to be difficult
for quantum computers to solve sometimes
we'll consider a more general version of
this problem the Rings this problem
where we basically replace all of the
integer rings by more general rings this
is hard for world chairs and rings are
and the only change you really need to
make is to define property what you mean
by the norm of one of the elements si
if the SIS problem is hard you can
design cryptographic commitments and
these are based on sis or maybe on a toe
is one way function if you want to see
it that way so the commitment key is
more random vectors a RMB I and you
commit to messages si with randomness
alright by using them to take a linear
combination of all these factors mod Q
and again this is a homomorphic and
compressing commitment scheme and it's
binding as long as the messages and
randomness values are quite small with
bounded norm okay so let's just compare
these two components for a second and so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
rewrite the pedestal commitment slightly
if I write all of the group generators
for the pedestal commitment scheme all
the GIS in terms of some common
generator G so GI is going to be G
raised to some exponent AI I can write
this other I can introduce this other
notation so AI with square brackets
means G to the power a I and then if I
rewrite Pettersen commitments in an
additive way we've got C equals the sum
of Si times these square brackets at AI
and now take a look at the on the right
hand side of this desist base the
commitment scheme it's a linear
combination of these vectors AI so they
look almost exactly the same actually so
our approach to constructing lattice
based bullet proofs is really just going
to be a find and replace operation and
we're going to try to fix everything
that goes wrong with the protocol so
what kind of results and proof sizes can
you get with classic bullet proof
approver can prove knowledge of an
opening of a commitment C to a message
vector of length M using to log M group
elements and this translates to a proof
size of of lambda log M where lambda is
some security parameter now on the right
hand side with lattice based bullet
proof they're proof sizes that we get
roughly roughly the square of the ones
on the Left I'll explain why this is the
case later on the left hand side the
knowledge extractor can actually find an
opening of the original pedis and
commitment that was used by the honest
prover on the right hand side we
have something a bit strange so in this
lattice setting the knowledge extractor
can only find an opening of some
multiple t of the original commitment so
this is a bit weird and I'll explain why
this is the case later on and why might
not matter
okay so right okay sorry about that so
let me hop back a few slides bullet
proof is it roots is this proof system
just here so it's one of these zero
knowledge protocols so bullet proof in
particular is based on the discrete
logarithm assumption and you can prove
you can prove knowledge of you can prove
something about something like I had no
constraint satisfaction problem of size
n with the proof size of log n so when I
say bullet proofs are referring to a
particular protocol which is in in a
published paper on this diagram
Aisling and then apply PCP based
techniques so you will have less rounds
you have faster verifier right so the
question is you know ok so right now we
haven't looked into concrete proof size
and the reason is that at the moment
we've just been investigating the the
proofs of knowledge to see if we could
get them to work and the next step is to
use the proof of knowledge as a
component in like a larger proof system
but actually prove something interesting
about I know some constraint
satisfaction problem and I think that
would be the interesting point to
compare practical efficiency there are
also lots of there also lots of tricks
that we haven't tried to make use of yet
so I think at the moment we're just
getting comfortable with using these
techniques and at the moment I'd say I'd
have to guess probably slightly less
efficient but I think the point of a
fair comparison comes later after we've
used all the tools in the toolbox right
yeah you you hope that you hope that it
should be possible to achieve something
because less is our very structured
we've got ha morphic commitments and
lots of my stuff but at the moment it's
it's not clear yet but that it's going
to be that it's going to be better just
trying to just trying to see what we can
do with these things really
okay okay so that was some information
about the criticises bye-bye a classic
and lattice bullet push on this slight
you mean just a vector commitment
okay so just when you use I should think
this would apply to an entire proof
system but when I write it here I'm just
referring to the proving knowledge of a
vector commitment yet because we haven't
fully worked out the details of you know
what it would mean to make a proper
entire proof system on the right-hand
side then maybe not clear what like
finding an opening of TC means for like
a generic say status effects of swaying
someone to a circuit or something like
that yeah exactly
I'll say something I'll say a tiny bit
about this later but I think it's
actually not that bad okay
so let's talk about some basic proofs of
knowledge based on the discrete
logarithm problem and based on this this
problem so let's warm up by looking at
the Shmuel protocol so in this
particular top there's a Patterson
commitment that the prove I'm verifying
though the proven o is an opening s with
randomness are to the commitment and the
protocol just goes like this and the
prover starts by choosing some random
masking values which is supposed to hide
the secret connect those and there's
over to the verifier they verify I
choose this random challenge and X and
sends it back to the prover next the
prove is going to combine the secret the
challenge and this masking value into a
response F and similarly for you and
then finally the the verifier is going
to check some equation on the
commitments and the prove his responses
so why should this prove that that the
prove actually knows an opening s to the
commitment
so the usual way of proving this is to
say that working so for a given first
message D if the approval is if the
approval is quite good then the prover
would be able to answer at least two
different challenges X with good
responses F that satisfy the verifies
checks if the prover can't answer for at
least two responses then it's not really
a very good cheating prover that's all
so they're given given two different
valid responses with different
challenges X and X prime for the initial
commitments we can actually do some
algebra using the equations of the
verifier checks so we can rearrange we
can get this expression here divide
through by the difference between the
two challenges and we can obtain a
secret s and randomness are which are
openings to the original commitment okay
so that's great so this this sort of
demonstrates that if the prove is any
good then they should actually know an
opening to the commitment see if they
can pass this protocol this is what
about the lattice version and this looks
a lot like national protocol we've got a
few cosmetic changes so firstly the the
secret here should have some kind of
small landed norm here when we sample
challenges and the proof of samples
masking values we need to think
carefully about what distributions to
use over small integers and how that's
going to work the proof I has some extra
rejection something and the verify has
some extra checks here I'm not going to
talk about those but this is how most of
the NIST post quantum signature
candidates look based on lattices and
they're really quite similar to
Additional Protocol except for
extraction so what happens when you try
an extract ensure that the prove
actually knows an opening to a
particular commitment so we could try
and do exactly the same thing as before
we've got these two equations that the
two different proof continuations should
satisfy
we can try dividing through by the
difference between the two challenges
and then we can get these openings s and
R okay so that's fine isn't it
well okay well the trouble is we really
wanted the witness to be S&R which have
a small moon and when we divide through
by the difference between these two
challenges mod Q we don't necessarily
know without knowing something more
about the challenge space that these are
actually going to be small vectors and
if X and X prime are just any two
integers then this value might not be
very small at all it might not be in the
message space for the commitment scheme
so this is a bit of a problem
how are we going to get around this
we have to be really careful about
choosing our challenge space so to have
a good sounds property we need to have a
very large challenge space but we also
want to be sure that the difference
between two challenges is small mod Q
and actually sometimes it might not even
be invertible mod Q so over the integers
a simple challenge space that we could
choose would be bits 0 & 1
this has a terrible soundness in this
case it's good in some cases where you
would want to give an amortized proof of
knowledge for lots of commitments but no
good for us at all instead of working
over the integers we need to work over
the more general rings this setting so
the ring here is some integer
polynomials in X modulo some other
polynomials and then there are more
different challenge spaces we could
choose we choose binary polynomials this
is a nice big challenge space but it
doesn't quite work for us and the
challenge space that we eventually pick
when trying to recreate bulletproof is
powers of this indeterminate so this
almost gives the invertibility property
that we want and it's a bit bigger than
this zero one challenge space so it's
going to give us better soundness
what do I mean by almost giving the
invertibility property that we want okay
so we want that to be an inverse 2x
minus X prime which has small norm we
don't quite have an inverse what we have
instead is there's always some Y which
when you multiply it by the difference
between two challenges you get two
instead of one so Y is almost the short
inverse to X minus X Prime and what this
means is that if the honest prover knows
an opening to the command line which has
a small norm the extractor can find an
opening with small norm but when you
follow through the algebraic steps in
the previous slides will pick up this
factor 2 in front of the commitment C so
the knowledge extract actually finds an
opening to a different commitment okay
so this is a gap there's another kind of
sign this gap you end up with in these
protocols and that's this so the honest
prover is adding together some secret
integers with small norm to do this
masking vector here so the response that
the honest prove is sensitive era Phi is
going to be made up of larger integers
than the original secrets and then in
the security proof the knowledge
extractor is going to be doing a
rhythmic arithmetic on B's to get an
extracted secret so this one is going to
be made up of much bigger integers than
the honest proof is original secret so
how do we set parameters for these kind
of things so the purple line at the
bottom is the size of the secrets that
the prover starts off with this blue
line here roughly corresponds to the
size of the provers responses that the
prove the honest proof it gets when
adding things together
the green line is the maximum size of
things that the knowledge extractor is
going to compute the commitment scheme
needs to be binding on all of these
that's the yellow line and then finally
you need this this problem to be to be
hard for messages on integers of these
size so you have to choose the assist
modulus much bigger so this so nice gap
kind of has a practical effect on
parameters sort of the smaller the
soundness gap the lower this yellow line
will be and so the lower you can pick
the lower you can pick the
the queue that you were using your sis
based commitment scheme to prove
knowledge of secrets of a given size
so now let's look at what happens when
we try and use all this stuff and think
about techniques from this bullet proof
proof system okay so when we want to
give a proof of knowledge for a
commitment to a really long vector we
could use this snow like approach but
then the response that the prover sense
to the verifier is going to be a vector
of the same length as the original
secret so this is potentially a really
long vector will have long proof sizes
and this is just this is just too
inefficient so instead what happens in
this discrete logarithm based protocol
bullet proofs is we have a technique
where we take these long vectors we chop
them in half and then we find a way
magically to combine the two halves
together into one short vector so we
have a reduction to a smaller size
problem and once we have this reduction
to shorter vectors we can do this again
and again until the prover can just send
a short commitment opening to the
verifier it's not quite as simple as
that so every time the prover compresses
one of these long vector messages the
verifier wants to check the compressed
message against some external commitment
to make sure the compression was done
properly so every time the prover
compresses a vector they're going to
commit to some additional compression
factors which the verify can use to
produce new commitments to the shorter
compressed vectors and this also kind of
makes the compression invertible and
makes makes it possible to get this
knowledge extraction property so in the
end we end up with the protocol that
looks like this so at the top the proof
will send the commitment to a very long
vector to the verifier next the proven
verify will alternate with random
challenges and these compression factors
and then finally after lots of
compression the proof who could send a
single element to the verifier so this
is much more efficient they should have
a logarithmic brew size in the length of
the original vector
so more precisely what's happening when
we when we cut a vector into the way we
combine the two halves together is by
multiplying the first half by this
random challenge from the verifier and
adding it to the second half of the
vector to get our new vector of 1/2
length and so if the two halves if the
left half is a zero the right half is s1
then the new vector s prime is easy to
write in terms of the old ones the new
compressed commitment that we get will
be written in terms of some different
some different group elements which are
related to the odd ones and then if we
take this new commitment g prime to the
power s prime if we do some algebra and
rearrange you can see that this thing in
the middle here this is our original
commitment to a long vector then we have
something else on the right something
else on the left and these will be the
compression factors that the prover
commits do so given the original
commitment to the long thing and the
compression factors the verifier is able
to computer a commitment to the new
compressed vector knowledge sign this
kind of follows the same idea as before
but just a much more complicated tree on
many different levels so the Neue
extract has to solve a lot of linear
equations and climbs up the tree
gradually obtaining and opening to the
previous original commitment
so the reason this bulletproof trick
kind of works out is because the
Paterson commitment scheme is more than
just homomorphic actually it's sort of
extendable so if you take Paterson
commitment if you break it into two
halves the first half looks like a mini
Paterson commitment and the second
Awful's it looks like a mini Paterson
commitment the Berenstain commitment
scheme is also kind of qiyama morphic so
if you have commitments to the same
message under two different keys and you
multiply them together you'll get to
another commitment to the same message
under a new related key and that's kind
of what makes this bullet proof trick
work so um so here we have say a
commitment to to to an original long
vector here we have a compression factor
and here too and then over here we have
a commitment to like a new compressed
vector half the links
okay and if we just switch over find
them replace if we go to the assist
based commitment scheme this kind of
idea is just going to work in exactly
the same way and this is based
commitment scheme has a really similar
structure and it just seems to work out
so one difference with the latus version
is that when you add the two halves of
the vector together the result that you
get is actually a larger integer to a
larger integer so we've added two small
integer vectors together and we have
something where we have a new vector
with larger integers there and actually
as we repeatedly apply this folding
technique the vectors will get shorter
and shorter but the integers in the
vectors will get bigger and bigger and
so this is one difference compared to
the discrete log setting where
everything takes place in some finite
field instead of the integers and
everything sort of stays the same size
this is gonna give us a big soundness
gap so the the The Commitments opening
that the prove ascends to the verifier
in the end computing that involves
arithmetic on M messages where m is the
length of the long vector that we had
originally and the knowledge extractor
is also going to do arithmetic on and
different openings to get an extracted
opening to the original commitment so
what this means is that we have sort of
a gap here which is polynomial in m
between the size of the committed
secrets that the prove originally
committed to and the binding space that
we need for the SIS based commitments
so foreknowledge sameness we trade the
same kind of thing as in the discrete
log based proof system we have this
large tree of different accepting
transcripts or continued in different
ways but when we try to use the same
method and have a knowledge extractor
which solves lots of linear equations
every time we invert the difference
between two challenges we have to put of
factors of two in front of the previous
original cannot nnessee okay so this is
the kind of this is the kind of proof
size that we end up with when we try and
use these these folding techniques to
get a proof of knowledge for a system
and that's opening so now here are the
reasons for the differences so we have
security parameter lambda squared
instead of lambda here because the
challenge space that we use is a lot
smaller than in the discrete log setting
and we need to repeat the proof several
times to get good service we have a log
squared M instead of just a log M this
is because as well as sending log and
proof elements we have to take into
account the size of the modulus Q for
this instance sir based on this slide
here the binding space for the sis
commitments and hence the the modulus is
actually dependent on M the length of
the vector and so this leads to an extra
log M factor and lastly since the
extract is repeatedly solving linear
equations in these challenges we end up
with a big factor T in front of C which
is o of M cubed where n is the length of
the original committed message vector
okay but let me come back to next
question now and the thing is if you
want to construct some kind of
cryptosystem which reasons about the
properties of a commitment c like some
kind of strong i know some kind of
strong encryption scheme or maybe a
group signature scheme which has
something interesting inside a
commitment it's really a problem that
this factor of T appears but if you want
to use the commitment scheme as a tool
some kind of auxilary tool for you know
for just containing a witness for like i
know and all NCS program or something
then what we found in another simpler
piece of work recently is even though we
only extracted a multiple of the
commitment we needed this commitment
also contains some kind of multiple or
scaling of a witness and we were able to
show that and and get back to all
witness so I think in situations where
you try and extend this to prove Circuit
satisfiability or something it's
probably not much of an issue but if you
have an application where you really
care about the original commitment then
this might be more of a problem so what
did we learn here and what are we going
to try and do next so we managed to get
this folding trick from the discrete log
proof system bullet proof to work but
all of the latus details the challenge
space and everything like that the sizes
of elements just got in the way and we
haven't even tried to use any of any
special lattice structures yet or at
least we haven't managed successfully to
do so
so these rings that these rings that we
used they have lots of water morphisms
and extra structure and there are also
lots of tricks from fhe systems that
that we could potentially use in the
setting if we knew how if we could find
a smart way to do so another thing we
could do is go back to some of the other
discrete log based proof systems and see
what happens when we try and convert
those into lattice based proof systems
as well we had some success with an old
scheme of Yuans growth which gave us
some interesting trade-offs compared
with compared with this conversion that
we did here and we'd like to try that
for other proof systems another thing
we'd like to do obviously is not just
stop with proofs of knowledge of
commitment openings and actually reason
about something like satisfiability of a
rank one constraint system circa
satisfiability or you know proving
knowledge of a witness for an
interesting and B problem but we made
some progress towards filling in the
hole in the green area of the diagram so
thanks very much
[Applause]
in the darkest Oracle the end the
assumption need is SS yes yes
[Applause]